have you ever wondered why children
often look a little similar but also
very different from their biological
parents or even how biological siblings
tend to share some common features but
still have different traits from each
other
to answer this question we have to go
beyond the physical traits that we see
in these family portraits and dive into
genetic inheritance
in this video we're going to see that
it's sexual reproduction a mechanism
used by many organisms to produce
offspring that creates the diversity of
traits that exist in biological families
and in animal and plant populations all
around the world let's start from the
beginning
all life comes from other life through
the process of reproduction parents
reproduce to form Offspring and during
this process they pass on their genetic
information to their offspring during
sexual reproduction two parents produce
offspring so each offspring gets a
mixture of genetic information from two
parents parents pass this genetic
information to their offspring via
chromosomes the coiled up DNA molecules
found inside your cells that contain
genes
sexually reproducing organisms often
have many different chromosomes each
containing specific genes for example
this diagram represents a complete set
of human chromosomes as we can see there
are 23 different chromosomes assigned
numbers 1 through 23. however there are
two copies of each chromosome so that
there are 23 chromosome pairs instead of
23 single chromosomes each chromosome
pair is a homologous pair which means
that the two chromosomes are the same
size and contain the same genes in the
same order however the alleles on the
two homologous chromosomes may be
different meaning that the chromosomes
may not exactly have the same genetic
information also in case you're
wondering the last chromosome set is a
little different because that chromosome
23 is the human sex chromosome which
influences the biological sex of the
individual but we don't have to get into
that just yet what's important to know
for our purposes is that sexually
reproducing organisms with two sets of
chromosomes in each of their cells are
called diploid
diploid organisms the DI indicating two
have cells with two sets of chromosomes
that are organized into homologous pairs
sexual reproduction occurs through a
process called fertilization and during
fertilization cells called gametes which
are egg and sperm cells fuse to form a
new organism
each parent contributes one gamete so
you might be wondering if each of their
parents organism cells are diploid and
Offspring result from the fusion of
cells from two parents how do The
Offspring of sexual reproduction
maintain the same number of chromosomes
well diploid organisms form gametes that
are haploid meaning that they only
contain one set of chromosomes when you
hear the word haploid you can think of
half because haploid cells have half the
amount of genetic information that
diploid cells have
a human haploid gamete for example
contains 23 single chromosomes one of
each homologous pair when gametes fuse
during fertilization that brings the
total number of chromosomes back to 46
or 23 homologous pairs
so why is sexual reproduction so
important well not only does it allow
organisms to produce Offspring but it
also creates genetic variation and
diversity the reason that Offspring have
different traits compared to their
parents and that one sibling looks
different from another can be attributed
to sexual reproduction this diagram here
helps illustrate how sexual reproduction
creates genetic variation the diagram
shows a cross between two hypothetical
parents it shows the chromosomes in the
possible gametes that the parents can
form and the possible chromosome
combinations in The Offspring so in the
diagram we can see that each possible
parent gamete contains one chromosome
from a homologous pair and during
fertilization gametes from each parent
fuse together resulting in offspring
that have a combination of chromosomes
from both parents and this is where the
genetic variability between parents and
Offspring comes from offspring are not
genetically identical to either parent
because they contain a mixture of genes
from both
the diagram also shows us that because
each parent passes on only one
chromosome from each homologous pair
there are multiple combinations of
chromosomes that can occur in The
Offspring for example the pink
chromosome from parent one can be paired
with the dark chromosome from parent two
and one Offspring and the light blue
chromosome from parent2 in another
Offspring keep in mind that this diagram
only shows the inheritance of a single
chromosome but in humans this occurs for
all 23 of our chromosomes and as a
result there are millions of different
chromosome combinations that an
offspring can inherit this is why
siblings can look alike but aren't
identical even more mind-blowing there
are other genetic processes that occur
during fertilization that increase
variation even more resulting in
trillions of possible allele
combinations for each offspring this is
why no two people accept monozygotic
twins are genetically alike
to summarize we learned that sexual
reproduction occurs when two haploid
gametes fuse together in fertilization
creating a diploid Offspring with
homologous chromosome pairs we also
learned that the patterns of chromosome
inheritance during sexual reproduction
lead to genetic variation in families
and populations it's why children look
different from their biological parents
brothers or sisters we've all inherited
different sets of chromosomes because of
sexual reproduction which in turn makes
each and every one of us one of a kind